i was born in uganda in 1950
and a year and a half later i slipped
out of bed one day
and i collapsed on the floor my parents
immediately thought
oh that's polio
it would be hard to imagine what a world
without vaccines would be like
it would really be quite horrible there
would be outbreaks of disease
regularly all over the world i don't
even think i'll be here
in a world without a resource vaccine
the true
deep impact and the global impact of
vaccines just can't be overestimated
[Music]
my grandmother she used to tell a story
about when they would hear
the bells on a hearse going down the
high street
a funeral she said as children they
would rush to their nursery window
to see if there were white ribbons on
the horses which meant it was a child
funeral
and they happened several times a week
[Music]
it typically affected children
one of the names for polio was infantile
[Music]
paralysis
[Music]
it's quite difficult to imagine a world
without vaccines life expectancy would
be a lot lower
people would have to lock themselves
away and only come out again when it was
safe
and ironically there would be such a
demand to do something that vaccines
would inevitably emerge
vaccines are likely the most important
public health
intervention of the last 100 years
they've saved over a billion lives
[Music]
with the rule out of vaccines we have
seen a massive reduction in child
mortality
in sub-saharan africa
i am born in the gambia and growing up
there i lost a brother to missiles
to lose somebody at a very premature age
from a disease preventable by vaccines
is absolutely devastating
vaccines can prevent cancer and there
are two kinds of vaccines
[Music]
with the roll out of the current malaria
vaccine we are expecting
to see a reduction of 40 of malaria
deaths
[Music]
you could bring a vaccine to people but
will they take it
anti-vaccination fears have been around
for over a century
we know from the 1850s when jenner first
developed smallpox vaccine
there were actually quite a few protests
a lot of it was about civil rights
and libertarian values there were
arguments saying that it was poisonous
that children who received a smallpox
vaccine would
develop bovine or cow-like traits a lot
of it was just a genuine knowledge void
that a lot of people had in the 1850s
that they still have today
so on the one hand we have the really
hardcore
adamant anti-vaccination groups but a
lot of people
are actually in the middle and i think
what we need to do is just engage with
people where they are and where they're
talking and not discount their real
concerns people you know want to
understand things they want to be
confident
they might be afraid of needles we have
to understand their context and where
they're coming from and what are their
past experiences with health and
vaccines
we have to ensure that people understand
it and they'll take it
having vaccines that people are not
taking will not serve any good
it's vaccination that protects not
vaccines
in a world without vaccine will be a
matter of economic
status where the children of the wealthy
who have access to health care will be
surviving
vaccines are the only public health
intervention that can bring equality
so women don't need to have 5-10
children just to see three of them grow
to old age
this isn't about just individual rights
when you take a vaccine it's protecting
yourself it's protecting your family
and it's protecting your community it's
not just a personal choice it's a moral
choice as well that affects other people
it's impossible to emphasize how
important vaccines are
and the reason that we don't often
realize that they're important
is that we've eradicated many of these
diseases the idea that vaccines
could be a victim of their own success
it's about taking things for granted
isn't
it and not looking behind what the
privileges we have in the modern world
are and what makes it the modern world
and makes it a safe place for most of us
to be
and vaccines are absolutely
at the heart of that they're fundamental
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video